die fellows caelers this is when mister
papers this gift so my fire
first lets alka bad rest er and vector
graphics
what the details mini sex and restaurer
mix is a great made up of pixels and for e
ch of these pixels with pacifier color
led al those is  in an image
is nothing but the collection of
pixels of for over a fire phone and
generally had images you encounter a
restaurer images
it is easy to see that the quality of such
images greatly deep en probe resolution
of discrete of course de madrid points
definer  the great is the nice dts weekend
see however in return to this regard
compression technically the file size
growth proportionality the number of
pixels en die friso min to close how would
you nest this classic strong effects
that i like to call
aliasing however i for  designing the
website and logo for companies which i
look sharp and all possible devices and
zoom levels
vector graphics is a useful from its
native vector image its inherent
different  from resturants is the
b-cells mens of the image varna pixels
wat factors and control point
the different things like storing the
shape of the circle of love pixel jump
point
must would be a restaurer match or just
saying that someone just scored a circle of those
we de gphin radius en as you
can see in this example the point of
this is to have razor-sharp images and
higher zoom level 6 wel en les wiggle to
grace' we define the tales pfizer als
olaf en remarkably small for vector
images have a look  who is next to malfunctioning the
colors of millions of pixels only'
story chips die vivantes aan de bit more
journal is this weekend mind of cd vector
image as having finished resolution
corner en zo less s much worse and won't
lose any the trade using  this process
vector relation is the process where we try
to convert
restore match 2 vector image samos
like to do this process simic tracing de
immédiate question arises why not using
vector graphics
everywhere
wel wat du  s there must be the color transitions
and the more detailed gave in her images
the quicker the advantage of factory's
chili peppers and to also note that this
precise is not real
and who as olaf en at the mercy of
directories shown a great time in terms
of  output quality
it is often a gland in advance
which allows you to work well on a green
input
so now i know everything we need to know
to be able to understand and the pleasure
once a sing along piece of work'
the input is there or sketch that is  a
restore mitch and the output is a
simplified cleaned up and vector a
version of the hoe year after toledo a
factorization and the simplification s well
this is a game changer bicky's this way
you can leave on the additional
knowledge de die is input restaurer
images ar  sketches and dry on images
therefore this and love extra fluff in
them that would be on design er boulter
the one in the vector ives output
therefore the takes sketch simplification
in each of these cases
h  et is absolutely in scene die how well it
works just look at these results
the next question is obviously get that
is wizardry i have a span using a
classic deep learning technique
i comb bon giorno niro network of course
that was training of the large number  of
input and the output press
however this is no ordinary
convolutional neural network
this particular area the first of the
standard wajon architecture and is
we argue the series is of
upsampling convolution steps into a
tivoli this area sparse
and concise representation of the input
sketches this most this focus is to
most finding features and pink we all
that to each fluff and die upsampling
combo lotion steps make it able to not
only understand it synthesize 0
simplified and high resolution images that
we can easily vector ice using standard
and grab  it is fully automatic and
requires no user intervention in case
your scratch jr had butties crumble
lotions
who has it pl  enty of discussions
about this peculiar time before helly
die op propriétaires as in the video
description box and think you find them
and love van
in one of them at pool data guitar and
added 3 verbree sandwich using camps
looser
it is clear that thai language of  on their
potential in using the fun combination
variations in deep your rollators your
brain that i my beeper earlier that
used by lady convolution versteht of die
hartmuscle syntus is this is a navel
crumble lotion variant' and this piece of
work' is no exception any
this  is already so cool online demo of this
technique that anyone can try
make sure to post your results in the
comment section we love to have looked at
your file is also have look at this tool
minute pepers feyenoord en next to lidl
logo
from far cry en fellow  shadow penny in
something great to see he has
sign your title had the series it is
speetile of you thank you for watching
and for your generous support na see you
next tim  e
[Music]